hey guys I'm just Miguel here to fill
you in with another GS news update today
we've got the revelation that apparently
consumers aren't that big on EA who knew
that's right Electronic Arts have popped
themselves into the running yet again
for worst company in America a poll run
annually by the consumerist EA managed
to grab themselves the not so coveted
award in 2012 and 2013 but whether they
can pull it out of the bag and make it a
hat-trick is yet to be seen anybody can
give their two cents on which companies
suck in the consumerist poll by making
their own nominations for the first
round EA has to take out time warner
cable to progress on to the next stage
of crappiness and consumer
disappointment the only other game
related company to be featured on the
pole this year is Microsoft let me know
whether you reckon EA is going to take
out the title three years running and
what you reckon they did to get into the
running in the first place was it the
battlefield for drama or some other
consumer educating move you can leave
your comments in the comments section
down below and be sure to check out
gamespot for all the new z things